the dance of dragons
it's the story of the fight between
ronira targaryen and her half by the
reagan for control of the seven kingdoms
a true telling by grand mr monken being
a history of the war of targaryen
succession between the princess frienera
and aegon
second of his name that nearly destroyed
the realm
one night a servant found the old king
had died in his sleep
protocol dictated that the bells would
be run and a raven sent to dragonstone
to summon the heir princess rhaenyra for
her coronation
but alison had other plans so otto
hightower the hand of the king and
father to queen alison
demanded that the succession be settled
immediately
the old king had forced the lords of
westeros to swear fealty to princess
rhaenyra as his heir
but sir kristen cole rightly pointed out
that her son
comes before a daughter
both of them thought they belonged on
the iron throne when people started
declaring for one of them or the other
their fight divided the kingdoms in two
brothers fought brothers
dragons fought dragons
by the time it was over thousands were
dead
and it was the disaster for the
targaryen as well they never truly
recovered
[Music]
during the great targaryen civil war
known as the dance of the dragons
a king and queen each vied for the
throne
dividing their house and its dragons
against each other
eventually the queen was fed to her
rivals dragon while her son watched
and the victorious king soon died of his
own wounds
by the war's end king's landing was
smashed cities raised and sacked never
to be rebuilt
and dragons had faded from this world